is the new 14-inch M2 Pro MacBook Pro
worth the money well it's been over a
week since Apple released these machines
and we have done a ton of testing and
while most reviewers say that this is
just a minor spec bump there are
actually a ton of differences so should
you buy this one over a discounted M1
Pro they can get as low as 1450 renewed
or 1600 on sale links in the description
by the way or who should spend the extra
money on this new model well jumping
right in they look almost identical the
only difference is that the space gray
one now comes with the color matched
cable the screens are gorgeous on both
and HDR content looks amazing these are
great for photo or video editing and
while I really wish that Apple put in
face ID at least the 1080p webcams that
seem the same have actually gotten quite
a bit better with more sharpness more
detail less artifacting it's a nice
Improvement now the keyboards on the
trackpads are the same they are
excellent and the same thing goes with
the ports other than the HDMI being much
more capable honestly the Mt Pro 14 inch
is the best 14 inch laptop that you can
get and it's very well balanced in terms
of performance and battery life which
I'm going to cover in just a bit now one
disappointment with the system is the
fact that the speakers now have gotten a
little bit quieter and the highs are
muted down which I just don't like I
like the older version go ahead and take
a listen
[Music]
now the last downsides I have to mention
before getting into the positives are
the ssds we still have 512 gigabytes as
the base model but they have gotten a
lot slower now we made a full dedicated
video about this and in that video we
showed off that the read speeds are
almost half as slow now that is because
Apple has decreased the amount of chips
that they are using which helps them out
but it slows the system down if you're
transferring large files it's definitely
slower now thankfully if you're
upgrading a one terabyte of storage this
problem goes away but most people buying
a 14 inch are going to want to buy the
base model so will this make a real
world difference well for most tasks it
doesn't matter that much but for certain
things that use a lot of ram it will for
example the Mt Pro was 13 faster in
Lightroom but if you're multitasking you
have different web browsing applications
or opened then the empty pro version
actually is 17 slower so that's a major
flip-flop and you definitely have to
consider that if you're going to really
push your machine now if you'd like to
be part of this exciting tech industry
but don't know where to start check out
our sponsor Full Sail University at full
sale you can learn all of the aspects of
computer science artificial intelligence
mobile development user experience and
game development in addition to other
degrees offered on campus or online full
sales programs will allow you to gain
hands-on experience while learning at
the pace of the industry Full Sail
University's computer science Bachelors
offers concentrations on artificial
intelligence and mobile development the
AI concentration guides students to
design develop and Implement their own
AI Solutions while the mobile Dev
concentration focuses on programming
languages for Android and Apple devices
if you like design the user experience
degree goes in depth on what factors
influence ux design such as factors like
psychology and perception visual design
and and systems design graduates have
worked with companies such as NASA Unity
Google and epic games to name a few to
find out more about these exciting
programs and how to get started click
the first link in the description below
or just head straight to fullsail.edu
maxtech and now let's get into the
benefits of the M2 Chip and if it's
worth spending the extra money to get
that now before we dive into performance
I have to talk about two major
improvements and the first one is
battery life the M2 Pro chip now has
four efficiency cores instead of two and
they are a lot more powerful and because
of that when you are doing light tasks
it can just use those efficiency cores
and not only does it give you better
battery life what makes a system run
cooler as well look at this we're
literally idling at 28 degrees Celsius
the previous 14 inch would get seven to
nine hours of mixed real world battery
life which was already pretty good this
one though will get 9 to 10 hours of
course that depends on what what you're
doing so that's a good 20 25 Improvement
unfortunately if you're really pushing
your system hard the battery life
actually gets worse because we have more
cores they are clocked higher and they
also suck more power about 25 and a half
watts compared to 21 and a half but
there is a secret weapon and that is the
low power mode now I was very curious
about this and I ran some tests and
unfortunately the M2 Pro doesn't mainly
use its efficiency cores when you put it
into low power mode like the M2 MacBook
Air does but what I did found was very
interesting pushing the systems in
cinebench our performance difference was
about 20 percent in favor of the new one
but the power usage was exactly the same
at about 12 and a half Watts meaning
that this system is 20 more efficient
but what was even crazier is that you
can keep this new one in low power mode
and the performance is basically the
same as the M1 pro model using its full
performance mode and it does that using
75 percent less power so that means that
if you do push your system hard with the
M2 Pro you leave it in low power mode
and this thing is going to be super fast
and with that the new 14 inch runs
cooler and quieter which is a huge win
in my book but what about the maximum
performance and is it worth it for video
editing the difference isn't huge and as
far as exporting the speed is exactly
the same now for photo editing we do
have some nice increases somewhere
between 20 to 40 percent faster so if
you do a lot of that it is a great
Improvement for gaming we're about 25
faster which is okay and for web
browsing and web-based applications
about 15 faster it's not that big of a
difference but the major difference is
for those that do 3 3D rendering the
difference is surprising and in some
cases it is almost twice as fast and
that's because Apple improved a lot of
the Buffer's memory in the Chip And it
is a great great Improvement so if you
do that it is absolutely worth it but I
think for most people if we step back
and think logically well you know even
the M1 Pro is fast enough and if you can
get it discounted for a really great
price especially refurbished I would
probably go that route unless you need
the much better Wi-Fi speeds or unless
you need a system that is super cool
super quiet and that gets better battery
life so personally I would spend the
extra money but if you're on a budget I
think the older one is going to be your
best bet check out the YouTube shopping
feature down below check out the full
comparison right there if you guys want
to see a much more detailed take with a
lot of performance click that Circle
above to subscribe and I will see you in
video
[Music]